hey everyone welcome to this week's live
session today's topic has stopped and
data analysis tools but before we begin
I'd like to thank our viewers on YouTube
and Facebook for actively participating
in these sessions so let's wait for a
while for people to tune in
you
if you have any questions do feel free
to leave them in our chat section and we
will be happy to answer them also make
sure to subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
now let's get started before I start off
with the top 10 data analysis tools I'd
like to talk a bit about data analysis
so have you ever wondered why data
analysis is important there are zillions
of companies across the world all these
companies generate a lot of data they
literally work with this generated data
these companies depend on data to make
crucial decisions which can impact their
businesses data in its raw format has to
be converted into meaningful information
which can then be used by organizations
this is done by analyzing the generated
data and for this we have data analysis
so what is data analysis data analysis
is not just a single step but a set of
processes it is the process of
collecting data then cleaning it
when I say cleaning it simply means
removing the irrelevant data and then
this data is transformed into meaningful
information we can simply relate this
process to how you make a jigsaw puzzle
just like how you gather all the pieces
together and fit them accordingly to
bring out a beautiful picture data
analysis also works on almost the same
grounds to achieve the goals of data
analysis we use a number of data
analysis tools companies rely on these
tools to gather and transform their data
into meaningful insights so which tool
should you choose to analyze your data
which tool should you learn if you want
to make a career in this field we will
answer that in this session after
extensive research we have come up with
these top 10 data analysis tools here we
will look at the features of each of
these tools and the companies using them
so let's start off
at number 10 we have Microsoft Excel all
of us would have used Microsoft Excel at
some point right
it is easy to use and one of the best
tools for date analysis developed by
Microsoft Excel is basically a
spreadsheet program using Excel you can
create grids of numbers text and
formulae it is one of the widely used
tools beat in a small or large setup the
interface of Microsoft Excel looks like
this let's now move on to the features
of Excel firstly Excel works with almost
every other piece of software in office
we can easily add Excel spreadsheets to
Word documents and PowerPoint
presentations to create more visually
appealing reports or presentations the
Windows version of Excel supports
programming through Microsoft's Visual
Basic for applications VBA programming
with VBA allows spreadsheet manipulation
that is difficult with standard
spreadsheet techniques in addition to
this the user can automate tasks such as
formatting or date organization in VBA
one of the biggest benefits of Excel is
its ability to organize large amounts of
data into orderly logical spreadsheets
and charts by doing so it's a lot easier
to analyze data especially while
creating graphs and other visual data
representations the visualization can be
generated from specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
Microsoft Excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it most of the organizations today
use Excel few of them that use it for
analysis are the uk-based company Ernst
and Young then we have urban pro we Pro
and Amazon
moving on to our next date analysis tool
at number 9 we have rapid minor a data
science software platform rapid miner
provides an integrated environment for
data preparation analysis machine
learning and deep learning it is used in
almost every business and commercial
sector rapid miner also supports all the
steps of the machine learning process
seen on your screens is the interface of
rapid miner moving on to the features of
rapid miner firstly it offers the
ability to drag-and-drop it is very
convenient to just drag drop some
columns as you are exploring a dataset
and working on some analysis rapid miner
allows the usage of any data and it also
gives an opportunity to create models
which are used as a basis for decision
making and formulation of strategies it
has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights it also has more than
1500 operators for every data
transformation and analysis tasks let's
now have a look at the companies using
rapid miner we have the Caribbean
airline leeward islands Air Transport
next we have a United Health Group the
American online payment company PayPal
and the Austrian telecom company mobile
comm so that was all about rapid miner
now let's see which tool we have at
number eight we have talent at number
eight talent is an open source software
platform which offers data integration
and management it specializes in big
data integration talent is available
both in open source and premium versions
it is one of the best tools for cloud
computing and big data integration the
interface of talent is as seen on your
screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly automation is one of the create
boons talent offers it even maintains
that tasks for the users
this helps with quick deployment and
development
it also offers open source tools Talon
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduced
significantly as the process is
gradually speed up Talon provides a
unified platform it allows you to
integrate with many databases SAS and
other technologies with the help of the
data integration platform you can build
flat files relational databases and
cloud apps 10 times faster those were
the features of Talon the companies
using talent are Air France L'Oreal
Capgemini and the American
multi-national peas are restaurant chain
Domino's
next on the list at seven we have nine
constants information minor on name is a
free and open source date analytics
reporting and integration platform it
can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining through
its modular data pipelining concept name
has been used in pharmaceutical research
and other areas like CRM customer data
analysis business intelligence text
mining and financial data analysis here
is how the interface of nine application
looks like now coming to the nine
features nine provides an interactive
graphical user interface to create
visual workflows using the drag-and-drop
feature use of JDBC allows assembly of
nodes blending different data sources
including pre-processing such as ETL
that is extraction transformation
loading for modeling data analysis and
visualization with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in memory
data processing
ix allows users to visually create data
flows selectively execute some or all
analysis steps and later inspect the
results models and interactive views 9
server automates workflow execution and
supports team based collaboration 9
integrates various other open-source
projects such as machine learning
algorithms from becca h2 or carers Park
and our project 9 allows analysis of 300
million custom addresses 20 million cell
images and 10 million molecular
structures some of the companies hiring
for 9 are United Health Group ASML
fractal analytics Atos and LEGO Group
let's now move on to the next tool we
have sass at number 6 sass facilitates
analysis reporting and predictive
modeling with the help of powerful
visualizations and dashboards in SAS
data is extracted and categorized which
helps in identifying and analyzing data
patterns as you can see on your screens
this is how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of sass using
sass better analysis of data is achieved
by using automatic code generation adds
a sequel sass allows you to access
through Microsoft Office by letting you
create reports using it and by
distributing them through it
sass helps with an easy understanding of
complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using SAS we have companies like Genpact
IQ weeow Accenture and IBM to name a few
that was all about SAS so far all those
were joined in late let me just quickly
repeat our list at number 10 we have
Microsoft Excel then at number 9 we have
rapid miner at number eight we have
talent at number seven we have nine and
at number 6 we have SAS so far you'll
agree with this list let us know in the
comment section below
let's now go on to the next fight tools
in our list
so at number five we have both our and
Pythian yes we have two of them in the
fifth position our is a programming
language which is used for analysis as
well it has traditionally been used in
academics and research Python is a
high-level programming language which
has a Python data analysis library it is
used for everything starting from
importing data from Excel spreadsheets
to processing them for analysis this is
the interface of our
next up is the interface of the Python
Jupiter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both R and Python when it comes to the
availability of Al and Pythian it is
very easy both R and Python are
completely free hence it can be used
without any license
I used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both R and
Pythian have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both are and
Python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using our we
have uber Google Facebook to name a few
peyten is used by many companies again
to name a few we have Amazon Google and
the American photo and video sharing
social networking service Instagram that
was all about our and Pythian at number
4 we have Apache spark
Apache spark is an open-source engine
developed specifically for handling
large-scale data processing and
analytics spark offers the ability to
access data in a variety of sources
including Hadoop distributed file system
HDFS OpenStack Swift Amazon s3 and
Cassandra it allows you to store and
process data in real time across various
clusters of computers using simple
programming constructs Apache spark is
designed to accelerate analytics on
Hadoop while providing a complete suite
of complementary tools that include a
fully featured machine learning library
a graph processing engine and stream
processing so this is how the interface
of Apache spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of apache spark spark stores data in the
ram hence it can access the data quickly
and accelerate the speed of analytics
spark helps to run an application in a
Hadoop cluster up to hundred times
faster in memory and ten times faster
when running on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in Java Scala are a Python
spark comes up with 80 high-level
operators for interactive querying spar
code for batch processing join stream
against historical data or run ad-hoc
queries on stream State Analytics can be
performed better as spark has a rich set
of SQL queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics etc Apache
spark provides fault tolerance through
spark RDD spark resilient distributed
data sets are designed to handle the
failure of any worker node in the
cluster
thus it ensures that the loss of data
reduces to 0 can be ver Netflix IQ eeeh
Lockheed Martin and eBay are some of the
companies that use apache spark on a
daily basis at number three we have
another important growing data analysis
tool that is click view click view
software is a product of click for
business intelligence and data
visualization click view is a business
discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and organizations with click view you
can analyze data and use your data
discoveries to support decision making
click view is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
Gartner Magic Quadrant on the screen you
can see how the interface of click view
looks like now talking about its
features click view provides interactive
guided analytics within memory storage
technology during the process of data
discovery and interpretation of
collected data the click view software
helps the user by suggesting possible
interpretations
click view uses a new patent in memory
architecture for data storage all the
data from the different sources is
loaded in the RAM of the system and it
is ready to be retrieved from there it
has the capability of efficient social
and mobile data discovery social data
discovery offers to share individual
data insights within groups or out of it
a
can add annotations as an addition to
someone else's insights on a particular
data report click view supports mobile
data discovery within an HTML file
enable touch feature which lets the user
search the data and conduct data
discovery interactively and explore
other server based applications click
view performs OLAP and ETL features to
perform analytical operations extract
data from multiple sources transform it
for usage and loaded to a data warehouse
the companies that can help you start
your career and click view a
mercedes-benz Capgemini Citibank
cognizant and Accenture to name a few at
number 2 we have power bi
paavo BIA is a business analytic
solution that lets you visualize your
data and share insights across your
organization or embed them in your app a
website it can connect to hundreds of
data sources and bring your data to life
with live dashboards and reports power
bi is the collective name for a
combination of cloud-based apps and
services that help organizations callate
manage and analyze data from a variety
of sources through a user-friendly
interface power bi is built on the
foundation of Microsoft Excel and has
several components such as Windows
desktop application called power bi
desktop and online software is a service
called power bi service mobile power bi
apps available on windows phones and
tablets as well as for iOS and Android
devices here is how the power bi
interface looks like as you can see
there is a wishfully interactive sales
report with different charts and graphs
moving on to the features of power bi it
has an easy drag-and-drop functionality
with features that make data visually
appealing you can create reports without
having the knowledge of ami programming
language power bi helps users see not
only what's happened in the past and
what's happening in the present but also
what might happen in the future it
offers a wide range of detailed and
attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards you can select
several charts and graphs from the
visualization pane power bi has machine
learning capabilities with which it can
spot patterns in data and use those
patterns to make informed predictions
and run what-if scenarios
power bi supports multiple data sources
such as Excel tech CSV Oracle sequel
server PDF and XML files the platform
integrates with other popular business
management tools like SharePoint office
365 and Dynamics 365 as well as other
non microsoft products like spark Hadoop
Google Analytics ASAP Salesforce and
MailChimp some of the companies using
power bi are Adobe AXA calls book
Capgemini and Nestle
moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have tableau
Gartner's Magic Quadrant of 2020
classified tableau as a leader in
business intelligence and data analysis
tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in Jam 2003
in Mountain View California tableau is a
data visualization software that is used
for data science and business
intelligence it can create a wide range
of different visualization to
interactively present the data and
showcase insights the important Redux of
tableau are tableau desktop tableau
public tableau server tableau online and
tableau reader this is how the interface
of tableau desktop looks like
now coming to the features of tableau
data analysis is very fast with tableau
and the visualizations created are in
the form of dashboards and worksheets
tableau delivers interactive dashboards
that support insights on-the-fly it can
translate queries to visualizations and
import all ranges and sizes of data
writing simple SQL queries can help join
multiple data sets and then build
reports out of it
you can create transparent filters
parameters and highlighters tableau
allows you to ask questions spot trends
and identify opportunities with the help
of tableau online you can connect with
cloud databases Amazon redshift and
Google bigquery the company is using
tableau argillite Adobe Cisco LinkedIn
and the American ecommerce giant Amazon
to name a few and there you go those are
the top 10 data analysis tools
let's now have a question and answer
session please feel free to post your
queries in the comment section and we'll
respond in the chat
before the question answer session let's
recap quickly in the meanwhile y'all can
post your questions in the comment
section below
you
so at number 10 we have Microsoft Excel
then at number 9 we have rapid miner at
number eight we have talent
at number seven we have nine at number 6
we have SAS R and Python at number five
Apache spark at number four QlikView at
number three power bi at number two and
finally we have tableau topping the list
at number one
okay so now let's get to the Q&A session
I can see there are a lot of questions
from our viewers let me go ahead and
address a few of them
so the first question is which
industries are using SAS and has SAS
become a declining tool since the
emergence of R and Python
well sass is used in different domains
of banking industry like risk analytics
marketing analytics and hatch analytics
sass is majorly used in the healthcare
sector for clinical research and drug
development SAS offers a wide variety of
packages for advanced level analytics
like SAS AML which is similar to our SAS
mi-nam
among others of course companies have
started using R and Python for ticket
analysis but SAS is still relevant and
remains a leader in almost every sector
of business usually small companies and
startups use R and Python as its free of
cost
another question I see on the screen is
I am a fresher which tool would you
recommend me to learn click who you are
tab you honestly you can choose any of
the two tools both the tools have a high
demand these days and a lot of companies
are looking for professionals who know
click view and tab view but both of them
have their own pros and cons tableau is
slower than click view when it comes to
in-memory processing tab lose interface
is more user-friendly and intuitive
click view offers phone support during
regular business hours which tablet is
not
okay someone is asking what is the scope
of Microsoft Excel in the future will it
get overshadowed with the emergence of
more sophisticated analytics tools
indeed it is true that companies are
inventing a number of analytics tools to
ease their businesses but Microsoft
Excel continues to be the most preferred
tool for reporting and analysis across
the globe
it is being used by junior level
employees and managers to understand the
data and build reports to make business
decisions
also Microsoft's probably a tool is
built on top of Excel so in future
Microsoft Excel will not decay at all I
hope that's answered your question
there is another interesting question
that is why has Python become the most
dominating programming language for data
analytics and machine learning initially
the Python language was created only for
application development and web
development but since it is open source
there was an opportunity for the Python
community to come up with libraries and
packages that could be used for data
analytics
peyten now provides a wide range of
libraries for numerical computation data
analysis and visualization as well as
machine learning some of these libraries
are numpy pandas man plot live Syfy and
scikit-learn so these libraries and
their functions make peyten the most
powerful programming language for data
analytics and machine learning
so that brings us to the end of the
question and answer session if you have
more questions please leave them in the
comment section below and we will be
happy to assist you with that we have
reached the end of this video do you
agree with our top 10 list think we
missed anything important let us know in
the comments thank you for watching this
video and stay tuned for more from
simply long
you